und wir schauen als erstes live auf das
bundeskanzleramt wo in diesen minuten
die bundes die konferenz zwischen bund
und ländern beginnt wo entschieden wird
wie es weitergehen sollen das sind
live-bilder hier aus dem man muss sagen
trüben und regnerischen berlin hoffen
wir mal dass das keine symbolik ist ja
und welche schlüsse ziehen die
regierungschefs aus bund und ländern das
ist ja eben die frage die wir uns hier
in dieser bild live sondersendung fragen
und die karlsruher richter der
karlsruher richter haben heute
entschieden dass die bundesregierung
in der dritten welle eben rechtens war
und der unter anderem darüber wollen wir
sprechen mit unserem bild vize power
anzahl der bei uns im studio ist und
direkt ein handy alarm hatten die raben
in diesem moment ist der
beschlussvorschlag reingekommen und ich
kann ihn vielleicht einfach direkt
einmal vorlesen also das ist der
vorschlag der b länder darin heißt also
die blb länder sind die cdu länder also
die sozusagen aus der union kommen und
da gibt es folgenden vorschlag
ungeimpfte personen dürfen sich nur mit
maximal fünf personen aus maximal zwei
haus ständen treffen kämpfte genesene
sowie für kinder unter 12 jahren werden
dabei nicht mitgezählt also eine art
locker und für ungeimpfte clubs und
diskotheken werden geschlossen da es
sich um bereiche handelt die mit einem
besonders hohen risiko für mehrfach
ansteckung verbunden sind bei großen
veranstaltungen darf die kapazität nur
zu einem drittel ausgelastet werden und
im gebiet mit einer außerordentlich
hohen 7 tages incidents können über die
vorgenannten maßnahmen hinaus gehende
beschränkungen begriffen werden und die
länder bitten den bund sofern die
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite nicht vom deutschen bundestag
festgestellt wird bis zum 10 12 das
infektionsschutzgesetz
dahingehend anzupassen dass die
maßnahmen der länder vollumfänglich zur
verfügung stehen das ist aktuell
reingekommen der vorschlag der länder
der cdu geführt der cdu geführten
ländern genauso sieht es aus das heißt
wir müssen noch abwarten was die
spd-geführten länder sagen und wie ist
dann eben auch in der bundesregierung
und ja wahrscheinlich nicht so sehr in
der aktuellen sondern in der die nächste
woche die regierung anführen wird also
die ampelkoalition sagen wird ich rede
ein bisschen weiter weg und brauchen
noch auf seinem handy weiter schaut paul
also es gibt eine dabei eine
protokollerklärung schleswig holsteins
und schleswig holstein sind hinsichtlich
der ziffern 2 und 3 die notwendigkeit
diese incidents abhängig zu gestalten da
geht es um clubs und diskotheken auch
hier wieder die debatte also schleswig
holstein mit einer geringen incidence
will nicht sofort clubs und diskotheken
schließen schleswig holstein regiert von
cdu-ministerpräsident daniel günther
alle anderen cdu csu ministerpräsidenten
wollen dass wir in einer koalition
zusammen eine koalition wie wir sie ja
auch jetzt im bund haben werden nämlich
eine ampelkoalition genauso sieht es aus
und deswegen ist sozusagen dort die
politik vorsichtiger aber vielleicht
jamaika entschuldigung nicht
aber vielleicht kann sich noch mal
zusammen also dass der vorschlag geprägt
auch von ministerpräsident wies nrw der
sozusagen den vorsitz der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat man
will einen lock down für ungeimpfte man
will clubs und diskotheken schließen
großveranstaltung nur zu einem drittel
aus lasten und die länder wollen das
gesetz noch einmal verschärfen und in
gebieten bei einer hohen 7 tages
incidents können darüber hinausgehende
maßnahmen und beschränkungen ergriffen
werden dass eine große frage was
bedeutet das dann für ungeimpfte dass in
diesem moment das aktuellste was man
sozusagen erfahren kann aus dieser die
jetzt ja um 13 uhr beginnen soll damit
allen ministerpräsidenten und das alles
vor dem hintergrund der entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgericht heute morgen
dass eben die bundes notbremse in der
dritten pandemiewelle rechtens war
genauso wie die
schulschließungen und die frage ist eben
ob das sozusagen auch als blaupause
genutzt werden kann für eine erneute
bundes notbremse und genau das hat helge
braun der noch amtierende
kanzleramtschef nämlich sofort im
anschluss anders urteil gefordert wir
schalten vor das bundeskanzleramt wo
unser reporter peter tiede steht peter
es ist ja eine digitale konferenz die
die heute stattfindet die in diesen
minuten startet wer es denn in persona
überhaupt anwesend
also olaf scholz ist da und natürlich
zwei ministerpräsidenten so wie sich das
gehört immer noch der berliner der muss
mit dabei sein weil der ist das war
jetzt schon den bundestag gewählt aber
ist noch in amt und würden herr müller
und dann wird herr wüst glaube ich mit
dabei sein aber entscheidend ist nicht
wer hier mit in persona da sondern
tatsächlich wer sich wo durchsetzt und
ob die union hier tatsächlich noch
einmal punkten kann oder ob die ampel
bei ihrem kurs bleibt was erwartest du
von der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
heute
also nicht viel es ist viel viel heiße
luft und die grundfrage die über allem
schwebt das warum soll ganz deutschland
eigentlich in den bayern lockdown es
gibt bundesländer die haben größere
probleme als es andere haben die
bundesländer haben eine um in der
sprache der ministerpräsidenten-wahl zu
bleiben einen großen besteckkasten den
großen instrumentenkasten sich bedienen
können es kann allenfalls so hören wir
auch als ampel kreisen nachgeschärft
werden also spd aus spd-ländern hören
wir auch es soll den vorschlag der schon
vor mehreren tagen aus spd kam es soll
gehen auch um die schließung von basen
diskotheken und clubs das sieht man ganz
als dringend an und großveranstaltungen
sollen abgesagt werden das damit man das
flächendeckend machen kann müsste
nochmal im infektionsschutzgesetz leicht
nachgebessert werden dazu ist die ampel
bereit das olaf scholz sieht christian
lindner hat das aussieht und die grünen
haben auch nichts gegen also da könnte
man tatsächlich an dem erst kürzlich
geänderten gesetzen nochmal rumschrauben
aber zu großen anderen sachen ist man
bei der ampel nicht bereit und wir haben
totales paradox aber wir haben momentan
ja zwei regierungen die am tisch sitzen
die jedoch geschäftsführend da ist aber
eigentlich schon weg ist nämlich die
merkel-regierung also die gruppe und
dann die andere dass es dann halt die
ampel und das sind zwei verschiedene
politiker das muss man einfach sehen das
glas eine wahl so eine art cola zentral
community wo man von oben nach unten
durch entschieden hat dann für die
ganzen länder wo auch die 16
ministerpräsidenten nicht sonderlich
selbstbewusst waren sondern dann gesagt
haben dann soll auch der bund
entscheiden wir setzen uns mit dem bund
zusammen wenn der bund zahlt machen wir
alles mögliche mit das ist vorbei dafür
steht dann olaf scholz christian lindner
und robert habeck dass das design leute
wir haben jetzt einen an die länder die
kompetenzen zurückgegeben das läuft wie
in einer bundesrepublik übliche strengen
der verfassung mit den parlamenten zu
zusammen und macht was ihr machen können
weil das pandemie bekämpfung ist nicht
bundessache sondern sondern irgendwie
ländersache und ein großer lockt und
wenn ja nicht hinzukriegen ist dann
macht auf 16 ferne lockt uns jemand der
faktor herstellen stellen kann aber
kommt nicht immer zum bund und bettelt
dass wir für euch die harten
entscheidungen treffen also die
bundesweite notbremse die helge braun
direkt im anschluss an das urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts gefordert
hatte siehst du nicht auf uns zukommen
einfach blanke polemik weil das
rechtlich so nicht möglich ist also
dafür müsste man dann das
infektionsschutzgesetz schlicht und
ergreifend wieder ändern und da ist die
ampel ganz ganz klar und wenn herr braun
will dass ein bundesweiter london kommt
da muss man mit dem ministerpräsidenten
reden da müssen hat die 16
ministerpräsidenten diese ganzen
einzelmaßnahmen so komprimieren dass
daraus dann ein de facto bundesland wird
und wir können und das ist die
argumentation die auch aus der ampel
kommt man kann doch nicht immer gleich
die größte keule die man im
besteckkasten hut nehmen und damit zu
schlagen sondern man muss doch abgestuft
oder man müsse abgestuft vorgehen von
land zu land die die voraussetzungen
sind einfach unterschiedliche und was
die ministerpräsidenten da mal erklären
müssen dass wir es kommt das irgendwie
saarland früh angefangen hat durch zu
pushen und durch ist hamburg hat eine
impfquote die de facto aber über 90
prozent liegt und warum sie dann in
bayern und in anderen ländern anders aus
warum haben die bayern nicht mal die
leute durchgepustet die sich bei ihnen
zweimal impfen lassen das sind alles
fragen die sich die länderchefs dann
auch gefallen lassen müssen auch vom
bund auch von der ampel auch von anderen
ministerpräsidenten
weil so groß ist die eintracht unter den
bundesländern dann am ende nämlich
nämlich doch nicht das was herr braun
macht oder was auch andere machen da ist
natürlich unglaublich viel unglaublich
die parteipolitik dritte da möchten auch
nochmal politiker die bisher an der
macht waren klarstellen wir lagen
richtig hinterher bringe ich erst mal
kurz ins trockene wir werden gleich
wieder zu der schalten wir haben auch
gesehen bei den vorfahrenden gästen im
kanzleramt erwies da regnet vielen dank
erstmal dafür olaf scholz wird heute bei
uns im großen interview seine direkt im
anschluss an diese konferenz der
ministerpräsidenten
und uns rede und antwort stellen im bild
schnelltest paul du willst das gespräch
mit ihm führen aber lasst uns mal kurz
schauen wie jens spahn der noch
gesundheitsminister auf das urteil aus
karlsruhe
reagiert hat da gibt es einige aussagen
die er direkt getroffen hat ich gehe
genau unter anderem hat er gesagt das
urteil schafft klarheit die bundes
notbremse war verhältnismäßig weil der
staat leben und gesundheit seiner bürger
schützen musste eine einschätzung paul
er hat zurück gerichtet sicherlich was
sozusagen das urteil angeht dass das
eben beschlossen wurde vom
bundesverfassungsgericht dass es diesen
beschluss gab was andere politiker
momentan machen das sehe ich sehr
kritisch denn zum beispiel markus söder
oder auch michael kretschmer die nutzen
den beschluss des
bundesverfassungsgerichts um jetzt zu
sagen dass sozusagen der bundesweite
lockt dann auch jetzt möglich sein
müsste und das ist finde ich etwas was
man so nicht stehen lassen kann die
situation im winter
anfang des jahres und der situation
jetzt ist eine völlig andere wir haben
eine impfquote von über 70 prozent und
man kann nicht sagen das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat damals
gesagt ja der der damalige beschluss war
rechtens das bedeutet nicht das ist auch
diesmal rechtens wäre das sieht man ja
vor allen dingen auch an den aktuellen
zahlen die instituts ist zwar hoch es
gibt viele neuansteckungen dennoch ist
die krankenhaus institute sehen
spezialisierung incident ja gar nicht so
hoch weil eben so viele leute geimpft
ist sind und weil die impfung nämlich
eben wirken wir schauen noch weiter was
jens spahn gesagt hat und zwar das
sollte jetzt auch den parteien
orientierung bieten die wegen
rechtlicher bedenken schärfere maßnahmen
bislang ausgeschlossen haben also das
ist ein appell an die ampel natürlich
gerichtet die ja die epidemische notlage
hat auslaufen lassen auch das ist genau
das was ich gerade kritisiert habe also
wenn ihr sparen jetzt sagt das sollte
ein zeichen sein nein das ist kein
zeichen da ging es um eine situation
anfang vergangenen jahres und es ging um
die frage ob damals die schulschließung
ob der lockdown ob das ob die schließung
von läden rechtens war das wurde mit
einem jahr des bundesverfassungsgerichts
beantwortet ob das verfassungsgemäß war
aber was jetzt passiert ist eben eine
völlig andere frage und da muss die
politik auch aufpassen dass sie da nicht
etwas benutzt und sozusagen sich jetzt
das urteil der dem beschluss des
verfassungsgerichts nimmt und einfach
sagt naja dann müssen wir das jetzt auch
machen genau dazu hat die und sparen
sich auch geäußert zitat schauen wir uns
auch noch mal an der urteilsspruch ist
kein freibrief für willkürliche
eingriffe in grundrechte bundes weiter
einschränken des öffentlichen leben zu
müssen zeitlich befristet sein regional
ausdifferenziert werden und sich am
pandemie geschehen orientieren
ja entspannt ist ja auch jemand gewesen
der dafür war dass die pandemische lage
die epidemische lake in nationaler
tragweite beendet wird er war mehr auf
ampel kurs als andere politiker und
stellen sich aber wieder um anschluss
hat sich dann wieder umgedreht und hat
jetzt wieder sich sozusagen auf den kurs
der eigenen partei und vor allem auch
der csu gegeben also das ist auch ein
ziemliches hin und her des
gesundheitsministers das versteht man
nicht mehr so richtig aber wir haben ja
schon einige ministerpräsidenten
konferenzen jetzt hinter uns einige ging
ja wirklich bis in die nacht was meinst
du wie lange wird das heute gehen denn
olaf scholz hat sich ja schon
angekündigt dass nachmittag er hier bei
dem studio ist es ja keine klassische
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz sondern es
ist eine telefon schalte wollte man das
benennen also die kanzlerin mit olaf
scholz und den länderchefs das ist etwas
was es in der form noch nicht gegeben
hat davor hat es sozusagen immer
eindruck gegeben dass auch beschlüsse
geben sollte also olaf scholz wird hier
irgendwann am späten nachmittag sich dem
interview stellen hoffen wir dass es
nicht früher abend wird also lasst uns
doch mal kurz zusammenfassen paul was
wir bisher wissen was wir an
insiderinformation exklusiv haben
hierbei bild live was aus der
beschlussvorlage der cdu geführten
länder vorgehabt vorgeht
beschlussvorlage heißt es das was man
empfiehlt zu beschließen genau das ist
das jetzt was in diesem moment dort in
der schalte diskutiert wird da geht es
um ein loch down für ungeimpfte am ende
also dass sie mehr oder weniger am leben
nicht mehr teilnehmen können sondern nur
noch zum beispiel die apotheke in den
supermarkt gehen können aber alles zweig
damit und ungeimpfte bleiben draußen bei
allen freizeitaktivitäten die es gibt
dann ist der vorschlag diskotheken und
clubs zu schließen bundesweit das ist
ein vorstoß der auch von den ländern
kommt und dann gibt es den vorstoss dass
man das gesetz also dass die ampel
koalition das gesetz noch einmal ändern
solle damit die länder diese dinge
überhaupt umsetzen können und dann
gleichzeitig gibt es die hoffnung oder
den wunsch dass bei einer bestimmten die
dance noch weitere maßnahmen umgesetzt
werden können das ist ein bisschen offen
gehalten in diesem beschluss da geht es
dann um die frage was dann zum beispiel
mit geimpften passiert noch mal ganz
konkret es wurden von clubs und
diskotheken gesprochen also nicht von
bars das heißt auch keine kneipen wenn
man das ein bisschen weiter
interpretieren würden und die
gastronomie ist auch nicht betroffen von
restaurants und bars spricht keiner
wobei man bei buzz dann definieren du
hast über clubs und bars clubs und
discos aber keine bars und restaurants
ja genau da also bei restaurants da geht
es dann um die definitionsfrage david
märz sehen wieder diskutiert wird auch
zwischen den verschiedenen ländern wir
haben ja schon einmal oder es gibt dort
sozusagen in dem teil auch etwas von
herrn günther der sagt daniel günther
der ministerpräsident von schleswig
holstein der sagt nein so können wir das
nicht machen das muss von der inzidenz
abhängig sein also da war man sich auch
nicht komplett einig bei cdu/csu
und jetzt wird man sehen was sagen die
spd geführten länder ist und wir achten
ganz genau dabei auf dein handy während
dieser ministerpräsidentenkonferenz weil
sobald wir nähere informationen haben
willst du dich natürlich mit handy alarm
bei uns melden